[Music]
welcome to the what podcast which bands
this year that matter it's fairy quarter
lord taco brad steiner and a fantastic
haircut
let's just start there
start with the haircuts
who you or me what what
because i'm is there a delay
you guys is your haircut is my new mic
microphone not working guys
anything
it's working fine what's wrong
all right fine if you guys don't want to
talk about my hair then that's fine
so be it
it looks great thanks guys
i appreciate that i did it all myself
i'm
i'm really impressed with that
microphone
oh you're more impressed with this
yeah then let me let me be impressed
with this here hang on
oh
oh oh
oh so
so i'm happy to see you guys uh i'm
excited to uh get going for
a uh episode that
i think that we've done in the past i
feel like we've done an episode like
this before but today
is a bona do
and don't
a bona do
or is it
douaru or don't eru which one's more
clever
do do that rudoo
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i've got a funny story to share too oh
really yeah
and it's and it's really it's related
so
you remember a couple weeks ago when you
were here we were in my basement and we
made some promises to give some stuff
away
to anybody who would you know order a
t-shirt because that's part of what
needs to be given away well
we got a lovely email request and an
order from
madison
and i'm not even going to try to say her
last name but it's probably a taco hey
it's probably smith
no it's uh
it's uh i think it's had zika i mean we
had to say her name a bunch because she
was a patreon oh that's right yeah yeah
so she lives in ontario very nice person
we did talk to her so anyway i finally
boxed it up picked up a bunch of stuff
which i won't
share yet because i want her to be
somewhat surprised but uh you know
there's some
some cds and stuff and some
what podcast related stuff anyway boxed
it up and i remembered that i think i
sent her something before and to mail
something to canada there's a form you
have to fill out
so i remember that but i didn't remember
that it was a big deal just a form that
you have to fill out
so i go to the post office this morning
find it fill it out feeling pretty good
about it but i realize when you write
out her email address you know it goes
across the line and down the line and
i'm thinking this is going to be an
issue
it's one of those jerseys where the name
just sort of like curls around the
entire number turn next page so i'm
already thinking okay
but there's nobody there right so i go
to the counter
give this to the the guy who's who's
wearing a mask he's got like this bowl
cut
he's kind of strange
i knew
i was in trouble
when he gets the form and he very slowly
looks at it and he takes out his pen
and where i had written my address
chattanooga tennessee in the zip code
c-h-a-t-t
he takes his pin
and he starts drawing an a
and it's the side i mean it's so small i
couldn't even see it
circle circle circle
and then he does it in
and then he does the oh
i mean
it
and i'm like oh this is not gonna go
well
and then he hands it back to me and says
okay you need to fill out what's in it
and i thought whatever i'm just gonna
make something up so i met i wrote down
three or four other things then he hands
it back and says you need to write down
the quantity of each
make something else up he says
you've got to fill this whole thing out
because i have to enter it into the
computer it's going to ask me and it'll
kick it out and
i'm like okay whatever
um
and he says you got to put a value and i
said it's going to be a made-up number
he said i don't care i just have to put
it in the computer
and
you got to understand i realize pretty
quickly that we have a case of somebody
who doesn't care
talking to somebody who is anal
to the
um i mean
um and we were loggerheads and all of a
sudden people start coming in
i'm there 20 minutes
with this guy he's when he starts
entering it
i had to show him my phone
to show him how to spell madison's name
because he couldn't read my handwriting
and he's typing it one letter at a time
and looking
and people behind me are pretty nice
until about minute 20.
and then people start saying i got to be
at work in 20 minutes you know and i'm
you know
staring the hole through me it was um
it was quite the ordeal
but we we ended up get oh that's the
other thing so he finally says there you
go what kind of how do you want your
receipt
i said i i don't care email is fine he
said hit that button on the
and
guys i'm not kidding the most archaic
old
enter your email system
showed up on the screen
and every time i would hit it with my
finger it would type in two of the wrong
letters
so i had to go back
pretty much you got a brand new email
today it would wow it would beep you
know and all this and that's when i
could really feel people and i said i
just you know type in something and
let's get out of here yeah
but yeah it was it was bad so uh this is
it's fascinating you went through all of
this barry because now you know how we
feel when you do anything
[Laughter]
well i told you yeah it was it was you
know a case of somebody who doesn't care
meeting up with somebody who cares
too much i mean when was the last time
you went to the anybody when's the last
time somebody's gone to the post office
this whole thing seems archaic
well because of
you know these merchandise that we have
i've actually been several times
so
all right so this is now
what i'm hoping people are like
if you're anything like me and i pray to
god that you're not
uh you would be
requesting everything from barry's
basement right now
just to get him back at the
post office to stress him out like
that's the kind of friend that i am
fair enough start making up names right
now yeah make sure it's international
i'm getting all of my friends addresses
everything i can possibly do oh what's
that do we know from pakistan
um well
i don't know i don't know if you know
this but they can look up the address so
if like you go in there and you got a
number off or a street off or it's
northeast and not southeast it'll kick
it out
so that's happened to me too they'll
look into it uh this this doesn't exist
you know and again there's people behind
me and i'm anyway it's uh yeah it was
pretty fun it's pretty good
i knew like i said old man started
drawing yeah old man gets out old man oh
that's exactly right
yeah
what about taco what's taco been doing
pretty much the same thing i knew that
was i knew that wasn't gonna be
different
did you
let's see did you see my free car i i
noticed something about a car but i mean
look
it's taco there's a car thing happening
all the time so i i don't know what i'm
looking at half the time so
i'm sorry i didn't put two and two
together
well
she left it in my driveway for eight or
nine months
and so now now it's mine i love how it's
just
she
[Laughter]
wow she loves it someone just forgot i
mean they just where'd i leave that car
uh-huh
no she moved out and never came and
picked it up and i i would bugging her
to come i would be considering that back
rent
yeah i mean she owes me storage fees
yeah
i mean she lived there she lived there
for i'm surprised she wasn't in the car
when you went to drive it away to be
honest
that's right
been using it as her closet
congratulations another car for lord
taco um
i uh
so i i i don't know if we talked about
this but i uh got to interview my best
friend
in the world uh mr winn butler from
arcade fire
um that was a uh highlight of my career
i don't think that barry would watch it
and think it was any good uh because i i
just sort of fanboyed my way through
about 20 minutes hey you remember that
time that we hung out
i saw a few minutes ago hey did you just
you remember that time that we we palled
around it was uh a little bit it was a
little chris
so the reason i bring farrell up is
because i have to do another one this
thursday and i and i really need you
guys help
i am interviewing
moniskin
okay yep okay um and how do you think uh
what
that's just knowing me the way that you
guys know me
what do you think i have so far as far
as preparation is concerned
i know the first question what do you
think it is okay russ
i'm gonna go with none
no i'm gonna go with what do you think
of my hair
oh close
first question i have
so you're a band
[Laughter]
yeah am i saying it right manuscript
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be about
eight minutes on makeup
uh yeah i got nothing i really got
nothing so if you have any ideas for me
please pass along some honesty tips
[Laughter]
yeah make sure you address it correctly
get an address
and make sure they can write neatly
would you guys like some random dvds of
babe 2
yeah thank you have you seen that it's
great
i can send you my list of go-to
questions when i have an interview with
somebody that don't don't do that
because we've asked them on this show
before and i don't want anybody to know
i said i didn't say i'm out loud
i have given up one of your go-to
questions yesterday and um you'll have
to dig my best yeah your best one you'll
have to go dig for that one um but yeah
i i'm i'm hitting the bottom of the
berry barrel uh when it comes to finding
uh questions to ask and it's a it's a
weird amount of pressure because um i
mean you guys know me i don't really
ever stress i don't ever really feel
pressure but it's just strange to to do
this for an entire company like it's
here for the entire
you know billion dollar brand that i
that i mean they've entrusted these this
billion-dollar brand interview
with this guy
you know and
i'm i'm this close to making fart jokes
every time i turn around and they want
me to interview serious artists this is
a very bad idea it's one thing to do for
a podcast but for an entire brand and
company this is
they've made some very very bad
decisions
[Laughter]
well it's what separates the pros
you'll get um you'll figure out those
go-to's yeah i don't know um so i got
that and then uh the other the only
other thing i was going to tell you guys
um
i've totally forgotten so there you go
congratulations you yeah i did
i did it yeah uh so see that's why
you're a pro well i mean it wasn't that
interesting to begin with i mean it's
i mean i did go to a mets game i got to
meet mr and mrs met
uh i saw that
mr matt yeah i saw that picture you met
the mets and meet the mets greet the
mets
step right up and i make out with misses
you had your t-shirt and your hat on
never knew you to be a mets fan until
what you know now i see this picture
really no i know you're uh
the redskins i didn't know you're a big
death fan
no i'm surprised by that barry quarter
no i just you know well i would i would
look to taco to be my backstop here but
taco doesn't even know who the mets are
[Laughter]
you're talking about yeah i know yeah
some dumbo sports yeah this is like kim
trying to ask me about a carburetor and
a camaro i have no idea what he's what
that is but yeah i've been a mets fan
since i was um since i was legit six
years old and i've told this story
before they had just won the world
series and my best friend
in little league was a mets fan and if
anyone ever tells you that they're not a
bandwagon fan and they're true everybody
starts their fandom out as a bandwagon
fan everybody because you like them for
two or three reasons one
they just won something
two
you live near the school or the team or
three you like the uniforms
as a child that's how we all find our
fandom is based on those three things
and that is essentially what we beat up
everybody now about being bandwagon fans
but at the core of us we're all
bandwagon fans um i
am uh i'm a die-hard mets fan because in
1987 i was six my best friend had a uh
love for the mets and they had just won
something so there you go i
we didn't have us we'd have a baseball
team in dc so i had to become a uh
yeah it depends on your age like you
know 17 1973 i was 10.
so you know notre dame was good the
dolphins were good and the cincinnati
reds were good so those are my teams so
there you go that's uh that's that's
that's all i got for you so that's
pretty much the show i got for you this
week yeah me too all right
so
bonna dews bonners and here's what i'm
thinking taco is when we go through
these for those people who are watching
the video could you do like a scroll of
bona do number one
blankety blank course okay all right
good uh for those who you know want to
read along
because who doesn't love reading and a
podcast
um
and if you do want to watch this um
subscribe to our youtube channel yes you
know what
on youtube it's a great point you should
subs like and subscribe everywhere and
then if you really really could do us a
solid rate and review
uh it's uh very important to the uh the
consequence people um okay we're
we're very close to uh our subscriber
number is very close to the wheat number
i don't know if you noticed that 69
no the weed number that's the sex number
oh it's all the same to me
it's all the same
on what what is our uh on what platform
on youtube
okay good that's very nice i wonder who
will be 420
who will be the 420th oh that was the
other thing i can't really talk about it
just yet but i reached out to the hams
kids because i had a uh i had a uh
interaction with a band they love a lot
um and i haven't followed up with them
but i'm just gonna this is my closed
caption message to the hams kids
you're going to love it you are going to
lose your mind um all right so bonnaroo
do's and don'ts so i guess we can go
around the room
i've got probably
seven to eight essential things that i
think that either even if you're a
rookie or a veteran things that you
should know things that you should do or
don't do on the farm some of which you
may already
do some
things you may already practice so if
you have any that you want to uh throw
our way that we can come back to next
week at the what underscore podcast on
on your twits and your grams i will
start
with number one bona do or don't barry
quarter what is brad steiner's absolute
number one do not break ever ever ever
ever rule of bond room
die i can i don't know i talk about it
every year i know i'm thinking
smoking
uh
hair care uh
smoking bathrooms
you have so many issues which
[Laughter]
i don't know where you're going with
this what is your number one the biggest
rule that number one rule taco you want
to take a stab at it
uh don't bring a hula hoop
[Laughter]
wow that's a reach back i do not want
it's fine to bring okay number one rule
no matter what biggest rule of bonnaroo
i don't care who you are or how good you
think you are
never go hard on thursday right never go
hard on thursday
okay yeah and what did i do you went
hard on thursday we all did that last
time i did yeah and and how did you feel
on friday it just ruins the entire
weekend you never get started right you
never ease your way into a weekend where
it culminates in a in a in a good way
especially it screws you if friday is
your day
yeah well
that's a great point and that is number
one it definitely should be and taco and
i were talking a little bit before we
got on the air and i still keep thinking
about this whole coming in on tuesday
now and wednesday
it almost feels like it's two maybe even
three events
so whereas we always used to say don't
go hard on thursday now you can't go
hard on tuesday now you can't go
tuesday or wednesday or thursday because
the thing had even started i think i
think that the way to think about it is
don't go hard on your first night
for earlier yeah just just pace yourself
even even though it maybe you get there
really
you know like on wednesday evening and
you're setting up some sort of campsite
uh i wouldn't go hard on wednesday i'd
treat it pretty light then on thursday i
would still be light i would still just
ease my way in because you really i'm
telling you i think the whole purpose
i'm trying to say is you really want to
wake up friday
with your best
version of yourself
you really want all of the energy that
you can muster on friday because uh that
begins the marathon and if you're
already blistered and getting iv shots
you're screwed
you're screwed yeah
it's uh it's going to be in the 90s here
this week and we're a month out
yeah i'm not kidding oh my god oh yeah
yeah they're talking low 90s here in
tennessee um
for those who don't know we're about an
hour away from manchester united oh my
god it's going to be into the hundreds
or in may yeah yeah it's going to be
warm um has anyone started looking at
the long range forecast yet
i haven't okay i have because you just
you never know but it's going to be hot
i mean we know it's yeah it's going to
change 50 million times before i know i
think the long-range forecast
uses i i don't i kind of like it i feel
it makes me feel a little uh comforted
even though it's total [ __ ] um
it's sort of like horoscopes uh it's no
freedom no they're [ __ ] yeah what's
it gonna be um but yeah definitely pace
yourself i i agree that that should be
number one all right barry courtney your
rule number one bona do bana don't
uh start hydrating now
now start hydrating now don't wait i
would almost say if you want to start
hydrating also start working out
start walking start walking do some back
bends build up some some core strength
if you if you can like muster that the
next two weeks
um
it would really i got made fun of so bad
a couple years ago and i'm like i should
start working out for bottom no no no i
have
i have no there's no question it's a
it's a lot of walking uh you're gonna do
a lot of walking
what's your average steps every day how
many steps you get a day now it's not
fair well i mean i know now but what is
your average for like you know in 2019
what was your average well i'll put it
this way
do you get three digits do you get to
three digits
i did the other day my wife works at she
works at a district and she comes home
and she's like i did 12 000 steps today
and i said oh let's look at mine i think
i hit 200
but i've been i've been working from
home so you know
it's not fair but it's low which is
scary given you know going to bonnaroo
i'm averaging this is going to blow your
mind since moving to new york i'm
averaging 17 000 steps a day are you
really yeah
wow yeah it's nuts
right and i think a lot of it's just me
like roaming around the office to be
honest with you yeah and just like the
the um the hidden steps like walking a
couple of blocks to lunch and coming
back you know sure um
you don't really think about that's a
lot yeah so
yeah that start exercising start
hydrating um
and start thinking about that um
along those lines you know taking care
of yourself
well
taco
bon adobe on a don't number one
um
you know every year there's somebody
that does this they get their wristband
in the mail and they're so excited they
just go ahead and put it on and tighten
it up
and then you they figure out you can't
loosen it to get it off that's a great
one that's a great so
don't put it on until you're in line
yeah and
and your your it doesn't
unloosen
it's just gonna get tighter
yeah it will just get tighter yeah uh
and i will say i had it wasn't a banaroo
but it was some festival i can't
remember what it was i had a straight up
panic attack because the damn thing got
so tight um i just had to you know i cut
it and i had to spend the next two hours
trying to get on a new one and it's not
easy and they don't make it easy for a
reason uh they don't want you doing it
yeah it's weird
considering
um my number one do or don't for lord
taco is the same every year and yet you
break it every year
i'm gonna get going hard
well in one way or the other yeah you
know what i mean
i saw that
uh you and brian stone i do you
brinestone don't follow my two biggest
rules
don't hook up at bonnaroo it's just so
gross every year
well i mean look at that guy he can't
help it i know my number two do or don't
bring stupid
don't be stupid
so
every year
at camp nut butter i purposely tried to
bring something a little bit more stupid
than the year before and it just makes
camp more fun
whether it's an outfit that is really
stupid
bring it if it's something for camp
that's really stupid bring it
don't bring food bring stupid
just don't be stupid
don't be the stupid guy who's causing
all the problems who's starting a fire
who's uh you know
doing karaoke at 4 00 a.m
also by the way
bring stupid
just not the karaoke machine keep the
karaoke machine at home
it's the only thing i'd say don't break
don't bring a karaoke mission so we
started with um if you don't know camp
nut butter it all started because we
were all you know just camping with each
other and i
hated it
frankly i absolutely hated the camping
experience i didn't want anything to do
with it so if i wanted to be in this
place that i love so much
listening to all these these bands that
i love so much i had to figure out a way
to make this work for me
so
i pitched to everybody at the campsite
hey why don't we um
why don't we get some carpet and uh some
sofas and a bigger tent
and they all looked at me like i was
insane
i was ridiculed
i mean laughed out of
of the entire festival until the next
year when i brought
700 square feet of carpeting
a giant 20 by 20 wedding tent
all of the the creature comforts that
the chase the chaise lounge the uh the
chest of drawers the sofa when i started
bringing all that that the coffee table
what did all of you say
you all said this is so stupid why would
you ever do this this is not camping man
what is it and then what do all of you
love
10 years later 15 years later
we still make fun of you and think
you're stupid um that's that's never
going to change but yeah we we
appreciate
or most of them probably do that you
bring all of that my problem is that
it's become my favorite it's your job
now yes that's job yeah i know yeah yeah
hey barry come by and get carpet guess
who down
taco yeah yeah get guess who has the
couch
me
so guess who's got to bring the company
the uh so then the next year after that
i decided why don't we make this disney
world and really make this thing goofy
so that's when i got everybody's giant
head made into a cartoon we blew it up
and we put it on sticks all around the
campsite and not only that but i made a
twister board with everybody's cartoon
head on twister so we had camp nut
butter twister then we created a giant
lit marquee that you could walk under
that was solar powered so at night it
would flash at you
i bought i mean
yards and yards and yards and yards of
white picket fencing to put around the
entire thing um we've got a long
you know row what is that thing that
we'd say it's like something from a
wedding that you brought when you're
barry that's our it's our yeah our i
never camping i don't it's like not too
old but yeah and then so year after year
it's a runway basically it's that yes
it's a runway and so every year we just
keep adding stupid to this a couple
years ago we added a mailbox a giant
camp nutmeg mailbox that we nailed into
the ground and we put a recorder inside
of the
mailbox so that anybody that opened it
will leave us a voice message on it
yeah that's right so you know that's the
kind of we then realize that everybody
at camp loves
um bloody mary's so we have a tent just
dedicated to bloody mary's because they
get sticky and dirty and we want to keep
that over there then we have a tenth
that's just for a kitchen
um there was one year that we only had a
tent just for the podcast uh taco shows
up he's got the bus
it really is a goofy experience but the
more fun and stupider you make it i
promise you the better it's going to be
yeah i agree
i agree which kind of goes along with my
next one which would be plan but don't
over plan which sounds contrary to what
you just were saying but it's the same
thing i i know early on
uh
0708.09 even when i was going by myself
i was
panicked
about
it was like i was going to the moon or
something you know i felt like i had to
bring everything with me for every
instance and every emergency and every
situation
and partly because of hooking up with
you guys and and then camp nut butter
figure out who you're going with if
you're going with people figure out what
each can can contribute yeah know your
role find roles know your role
yeah you know not everybody has to bring
the same yeah that's right um
like the bloody mary 10 i mean i think
we all
you know pitched in and brought
something and
thought about it and somebody had the
tent somebody had a table you know that
kind of thing you don't have to
you don't have to go buy everything all
at once and if you're coming by yourself
um
make friends
make friends plan making friends make
friends talk to the person next to you
if i actually you know what you should
do just find the people with the really
cool setup and just
link onto them
just
grab them and don't let them go
preferably some sort of brewery that's
set up because they're the ones that are
going to have all the fun poses
bring something that uh can you know
introduce you to
as being a good neighbor yeah you know
whether it's brewery from your where
you're from or food item whatever
um
but worry worry about the hydration
worry about comfort worry about your
your tent your air mattress
uh those sorts of things but don't worry
about feeling like you have to bring
everything i feel like to that point i
mean it lends into another thing that
you talk about all the time
uh
let the schedule be a guide
not gospel
you want the schedule to be just an
outline of what your day might be you
might find one artist that you
absolutely have to see
i wouldn't do any more than that
i wouldn't over commit yourself to more
than two
three bands
a day tops that you absolutely have to
see because you're just going to keep
yourself from experiencing things that
are are happening all around you that
you
you know
not necessarily as important as seeing
you know dozier cat again
i want to i want to hear tacos the next
one but then i want to ask him a
question related
so go ahead what's your next one
i mean uh probably it's in line with
what y'all said i mean make friends with
your neighbors early
and
i would say bring you know a lot of
people will bring you know cards or
stickers or little trinkets to hand out
if you can come up with something
that when you meet somebody you give
them a little something you know maybe
you exchange
stickers or cards or you know little
figures or something just
that makes it more fun when you meet
people and you know you get then you get
to take something back with you and just
keep to that point i'm glad you brought
that up years ago i took everybody's
giant cartoon head on a stick and made
stickers
that you could then take the sticker and
place it around
camps so you could take it to town bring
it to town and
paint your city with your bonnaroo
sicker i love that idea taco i really do
love that idea
yeah and along those lines it's part of
why i ask is you're you've started in 18
right right so you're the
you're the newcomer in this trio brad
and i are both what oh seven i think the
newest one um
so you and and you're probably
the most uh social
in that you probably made the most
friends
because of the festival i mean i know
brad and i have but i mean you've made
friends that you speak see and speak to
pretty regularly right uh because of
this podcast because of bonnaroo so
that's another thing i i guess i would
say to people those those friend
tentacles they extend into regular life
yep throughout the whole year yep tacos
good credit to that
yep
yeah i've made a ton of friends that i
talk to nearly on an everyday basis now
because of because of bonnaroo because
of the show yeah so come with that open
mind ready to make
make friends don't worry about coming
alone i guess would be my don't in that
regard
we know lots of people that come from
all over the country by themselves
who have a great time
so i mentioned don't let the schedule be
your gospel let it be your guide i will
say two things one
let the phone go
and two
make the schedule take a picture of it
and make it your home screen each day
when you wake up in the morning
i uh read this tip and i don't remember
where it was years ago but boy that
saves so much battery on my phone if
you've got an external that's really
nice but it's so good to just like pop
the home screen on like oh look okay
what do i have it's so much easier it
cuts down so much time and
uh you don't have to you know you know
carry around a stupid
laminated
schedule like brian stone does every
year which is always wrong
it's always wrong
yeah that the phone is another good one
yeah put it down don't don't come
thinking you're gonna your phone is
gonna be your lifeline like it is
probably every other day of the year
it's not gonna work you're not gonna be
able to text your friends you're not
gonna be able to keep up with your group
via phone
well there you go
i will say the year that the attendance
is really bad phone worked perfect
it could be good this year it could be
very good this year but don't don't
count on it
yeah don't don't count on the
uh don't count on your your phone like i
said be in your lifeline
um like like we all
have become accustomed to um and really
you don't want to enjoy the enjoy all
right lord taco you're next another one
uh
barry you thought you said you had a
question for me or
no he did oh you answered it i was
asking about the
being open to uh meeting new people and
and basically just being ready for that
i guess
the other part of the question was
how how much did you and do you
uh ask other people i mean you you're in
the bus you camp all the time you can't
pretty much every week so camping is
nothing new for you
uh but what are the things you've
learned
in the in the two or three that you've
been there
uh that maybe you're different
that you would tell people that are
coming to camp that are different than
you know they're going to go to the lake
right
you know like we said uh make friends
with your neighbors do that early do
that as soon as you are setting up
because chances are you're going to
forget something and you might have to
ask hey you know i need to borrow
something or they're going to forget
something and they're going to ask you
and then once your friends it's nice to
uh just know that somebody's around like
if you if they're back at camp and
you're at the show they're gonna keep an
eye on your campsite you know just in
case
in case something happens so
um making neighbors or sharing or oren
taco or in taco or brian's case you
might end up sleeping with them for you
or that too maybe yeah yeah maybe there
maybe they have a better air mattress
than you do
i don't know i came back and talked
those buses on two wheels
what the hell is going on
we got the queen-size air mattress
[Laughter]
uh
let me jump in the other because you
talk
making friends is also familiarize
yourself uh
with where you are get to get your
landmarks
uh and and get them uh pay real
attention to them because the place
looks a whole lot different at night
than it does during the day that's so
true
uh because as a guy who got lost his
first year of bonnaroo
it was the worst feeling in my world now
worst feeling in the world now it's a
little different i mean they've got
things a lot more lit and you know much
more
put together with the signage and
um but boy that those first couple of
years where you had if you took a let's
put it this way if you took a wrong turn
you're walking for half an hour
because there was no signage you had no
idea where you were going
and if you didn't if you were if you
were coming back blistered
you had no idea where you were going and
i got so lost one night i was literally
thought i was in the opening scene of
lean on me i was so scared for my life i
was like what is happening around me
oh it was awful
yeah but that's what i mean by get good
landmarks like don't go with the gray
honda
you know
turn left at the gray honda cuz there's
gonna be more i don't i wonder if that's
even a thing anymore barry i don't know
if you really need those because the
if you go out in the center of the air
into ga there's like there's flags
everywhere there's spotlights everywhere
there are but that's what i'm saying if
you don't pay attention to like
like you know you remember the year the
the girls they got so
high or whatever they were and they
finally they came up and they noticed
our camp and how many people did we have
come up and say thank you guys for the
marquee and the signs because that's
what we use is our which is sad because
back where we camp there's only two
roads
but when it got dark when it got dark it
could look it could be a little strange
so that's my point
yeah so pay good attention to uh some
sort of landmark that's gonna look the
same
no matter what time of day norm or you
know how how
uh
altered my uh my next bona do bona don't
it's uh along the lines of making
friends
do something nice
for someone every day
it doesn't have to be something big it
doesn't have to be
but just
one nice thing a day the karma the karma
that you put into the farm will come
back to you in ways that you've never
expected
so just
pass it along and maybe buy a
buy the spicy pie for the guy behind you
just once
maybe uh
you know uh you know
give the guy a uh some batteries who
might need it you know anything that
that helps your fellow roofie and just
one time a day it's going to come back
to you um twofold yeah
somebody looks like they're struggling a
little bit or lost or check on somebody
or whatever just speak yeah check on
them don't walk over don't step over
check on them and uh that's that's a
great point and that and i think
especially if this is your first time
um
i really think
you'll find that that's the code that's
part of the code and it's real
and it's why we have a podcast it's why
we talk about this year round is
that that's a very real thing and it's
it's pretty cool i leave there every
year thinking why can't everything be
like this
just be nice i mean especially in the
world that we're in today i mean every
day it's just more shitty news over and
over and over this is the one place that
we come to that is
just
four five six seven we hope eight days
that's just not shitty
you know that we're not just
totally encompassed with bad news and
terrible headlines we
we get we get a few days of being
totally good to each other in in a in an
idealistic world
do something nice for somebody if you
can every day
yeah that's a great point let me go back
to the schedule
that's a great that's a great point
the schedule hopefully you're not here
for the interrupt
barry we are 37 38 minutes in taco has
not opened one pbr yet
what has happened here are you okay russ
uh yeah give me a minute i'll go i'll go
get one speaking of checking on
something all right should we all pause
and go get uh you want to take a pbr
break
let's go get a sip sip
that's
that's funny you know brad was just
talking about having a wellness check
i'm trying to do something nice for
somebody yeah you're trying to look out
for me and i am getting a little thirsty
well wellness check on taco
all right be right back
welcome back to the what podcast
it is
an episode dedicated to the do's and
don'ts of bonnaroo for those uh that are
new to the festival uh this is a good
starting place for those who have been
to the festival as bonnaroo veterans
maybe it's a good refresher time as you
start to pack your gear
double check your stuff
give it that once over before it goes in
the car
this is it we're going to try to do our
best if there's anything we missed let
us know the what underscore podcasts on
the gram and the twits
you want to hear you want to hear the
greatest sound in the world yes i'm
ready
it's very loud that was a good one all
right cheers here we go i gotta i got
this new
all these new brooklyn and new york
breweries i'm trying this is a sloop
super soft
what's super soft don't worry about it
it doesn't it's not something you'll
never taste did it win a blue ribbon
not yet just wait okay not yet not yet
all right
what i was gonna say about the schedule
you're uh
uh it should be coming out here soon if
it hasn't already by the way we're gonna
do it
yeah we're gonna do it it's always fun
take it make your list study it i mean
that's it what we're all gonna do for
the next four weeks
is
we're gonna try to make a schedule that
we want to see
have fun with that do it get i mean i
think it helps get in your head what's
going on
um
but like brad said you're never gonna do
it so
have fun with it but uh don't bury
yourself go see something that's not on
your list yes go see something it's not
in your life stand for that
plan for that if you that should be
everyone's goal you everyone's goal
should be to leave there with at least
one
or more act that you had no idea and
never heard of that you now love
that's to me is a successful you know
the the seeing a favorite act and it
blowing your mind is great
and that does happen but for me it's
coming away with uh new favorites um
next up taco you got another one
i would say now i mean we're what 30
days right now wait now is the time to
start
i would not necessarily packing but you
need to have a spot in your house to
throw
bonnaroo stuff start getting it out
especially if you haven't been in a
couple years you might need to uh search
your house for all of your camping stuff
all your supplies
and you're gonna think of stuff in the
middle of the day and be like oh i need
to grab that just go ahead and throw it
in the pile so that it's all there to
put in the car
it's a it's a great point because
scheduled day was always the day barry
that
we would all get together that would be
the day we brought camp nut butter
together for the first time in 300 and
you know 35 days
everybody would get together we'd have a
meeting
we'd go through the stuff that we wanted
to see and then we'd all say okay
what do we have left what is our stuff
like uh does everybody still have blank
do you still have blank this is the time
to not only check your stuff but check
it on your other uh your other camp
members stuff and to see what they have
and just coalesce around um
what you need what you don't need and um
again you know what you don't need dry
ice
no don't don't do stop with the dry ice
and frankly you don't need food
you need basic food stuff you need
sandwich stuff you need you know bars
and and quick
fuel but you do not need a grill you do
not need
massive amounts of food the food there
is world class you do not need food
yep that was that was my biggest mistake
the first year because i'm
i've gone camping and i'm used to
bringing my own food because you know
you're out in the woods so i packed is
this as if i'm going out in the woods to
be alone for that's right i brought all
this food
you know eggs and
you know burgers and stuff and i threw
it all away because you know even if
you're like oh i'm hungry i should make
something you don't have time for it
right oh but this vendor over here is
really good i can just go over here
you know plus again you do not have time
unless it's really early in the morning
or really late at night you will not
have time to make food
so what a waste of time to sit there and
try and gr one guy did come one year um
and make us like eggs one morning and
that was fine that was adorable and cute
but i don't want to do that every day
yeah no it was a lot and i to taco's
point about uh find a place in your
house put everything yeah start making a
pile i mean
how many times have we left there with
like a tentpole that broke
you know currently if if anyone's
listened to any of these other shows
barry's currently in his bonnaroo room
everything down there has just been
thrown there at some point it's like a
previous batteries pretty much
pretty much it went and when i come home
i try to pack it and you're about to
leave again
if
yeah because i don't want to try to
remember try to rely on my brain to
remember oh that tent pole is broken or
i need to replace that yeah speaking of
whatever go ahead and assemble your tent
your easy up whatever you got just to
make sure everything's there and that
it's not broken because you don't want
to
i always put it up
yeah you don't want you don't want to
get there and find out the rats have
eaten it or you forgot something or it's
dry by the way i didn't really realize
that was a thing barry
rats ate through my my tent
we were gonna we're gonna have to buy a
whole new tent this year
but yeah it happens i mean moths yeah
but it turns out whatever we will not
need to buy a new tent because of the
bonnaroo donated tents to new orleans
there were extras left over
oh nice
very good very nice
yeah very nice thank you bonnaroo um
so yeah i always put my tent up
the week of and pack it and i mean i
pretty much keep my stuff
in the you know it's ready to go like
it's a go bag type of thing
um plan for those extra days this year
um
that's that's something that's going to
be a little bit different for veterans
especially those of us that are thinking
about going that tuesday or wednesday
i just i can't
that and the whole there's so many
different events planned out in the
plazas and whatever
those those to me are the things that i
can't
quite wrap my head around how it's going
to change the function of yeah of your
just day-to-day operations and yeah
that's a good point too um
plan on doing something out in the
campgrounds one day because there's so
much well that's where everybody is taco
yeah
well but i mean like no there's actual
events happening like
and you could miss him if you're in
center all the time there's there's
where in the woods there's something at
every single plaza there's you know
pop-up shows there's stuff going on that
uh there's the bear exchange we haven't
even talked about the beers they're
trading bears
yeah oh beers you got it beer
can we be honest though if i would have
said that you guys would have
annihilated me if i would have said go
out to the camp the general admission at
one time come on guys you guys
yeah it was never in the never on our
radar
uh i agree uh yeah it's it really is and
by the way the beer exchange is really
fun just um you know
be aggressive with that beer exchange
because uh people get way too nice and
they are uh i was way too nice that
first year i wish i would have really
been more aggressive uh i'd like to get
into like the self-care section of the
do's and the don'ts i've got a few
self-care
tips
from the biggest diva in the history of
bonnaroo campers
i don't know if you in your life know
anybody that does yoga or is a health
coach or
likes voodoo medicine uh but
i know a lot of it sounds like [ __ ]
but i'm gonna change your bonner life
for a second
the minute that the wife brought this
item to camp it changed my entire
bonnaroo existence
let me introduce you to what is called
a yoga wheel
now i know this wheel looks like just a
random
ridiculous thing
but if you learn how to use it
you roll on it the middle of the night
before you when you get out of bed
because bed is stiff the air mattress is
not working maybe you didn't sleep so
well you get on this yoga wheel and
everything changes
i say this to you if you hear nothing
more that i say for the rest of time
do the yoga wheel find a space in your
car for the yoga wheel because if you
get your back on this if you're back if
you have a tiny bit of back problem
right if your back hurts just a little
bit
roll on the yoga wheel
everything changes
i can't stress this south
along those lines uh
dress for comfort
dress for the heat dress for dust dress
for dirt bring comfortable shoes
comfortable clothes don't dress thinking
i don't i don't i don't actually agree
with that i'm gonna actually push back
on that because
i think that if you want to show up
and know what you're getting into
wearing something ridiculous like i
don't know taco's tyrannosaurus rex
costume i don't know i think it would be
i think it'd be fun but you just got to
know what you're getting yourself into
no i'm i guess what i'm thinking is
the first couple of years the the tivas
everything that you read was wear
sandals with straps because when you
step in a mud puddle your shoe is going
to come off or your sandal is going to
come off and you'll never get it back
so i mean i i did all that and i didn't
want to ruin like good tennis shoes
and then after about the third or fourth
year i'm bringing my good tennis shoes
and i'm gonna be comfortable walking and
you know just don't step in a mud puddle
or whatever that's that's part of what
i'm talking about and
i tell you i tell you me and nick turner
if you want to wear angel wings and
dinosaur costumes whatever you have
about it but i hear but let me let me
this is what me and nick turner realized
a few years ago we would
men's shoes are pretty inexpensive you
can get a 50 pair of vans
and get the insoles put in them and
you've got a pair of shoes that if they
get destroyed a bonnaroo
who cares who cares
even nick bought you know he bought a
brand new pair of fans and this idiot
decided to get stark white vans
just so that he could see how disgusting
they would be by sunday and they were
horrid
horrid
so um don't
if you're going to spend money on
something
knowing that you're probably not never
going to use it again buy a you buy a
mid-range pair of vans get the insoles
and you just prepare for them to not
come back no that's a good point which
one of you is running a vacuum cleaner
all of a sudden
somebody's mowing me 90-degree heat um
yeah don't i i guess to amend what i
said don't you know buy 400
shoes because they're comfortable
because you might step in a mud puddle
or a dust but uh
but uh plan on walking and dress
accordingly i guess and plan on being
hot and dress accordingly is what i'm
about the other the other self the self
um
care
piece that i'd give you
i know this sounds weird but i have a
big problem breathing when it gets hot
um oh it is taco taco you've got a
neighbor doing some yard work buddy uh
so
i know this sounds crazy but it gets
really hot and i have a tough time
breathing when it's hot so we bring
essential oils
peppermint breathe oil if you know
doterra like peppermint oil is fantastic
not just to put under your nose or your
chest to help you breathe but boy you
put some of those drops on an ice cold
uh towel that you've dipped the towel
and then put the drops in the towel and
then wrap that around your neck
that's nice your body temperature
changes by 10 10 degrees
for sure uh
all right speaking of uh dressing for
the heat you want to hear i've got the
forecast pulled up for the month you
want to hear the whole month i'm ready
it says right now and then well
yeah go ahead guess high of 92
chance of showers 20
and not quite 92 the highest it gets is
87 on saturday
uh yeah like 82 eighty-four eighty-seven
it's pretty much the whole week not too
bad it's not bad uh the the lows is like
63-64.
by the way i'm glad you brought that up
taco it gets cold at night yeah it gets
very cold at night prepare to bring
hoodies a blanket to sleep under that's
going to be warm i know it takes up a
lot of space but it dinosaur onesie it
really will freeze you out at night it
is super super cold especially when the
wind starts moving through the the farm
during the shifter on the ground because
you're sleeping on the ground it didn't
used to but last ten or eight or nine
years it's gotten really cold at night i
mean i've been i've been so unprepared
for the cold that i have left shows in
the middle of it at one two o'clock in
the morning because it's just too damn
cold sure i agree
yeah plan for that uh plan for rain
uh you know bring up poncho whatever um
something you can carry with you and
have with you
uh along those lines
don't bring a lot to carry especially if
you're gonna go you know into cenaru i
mean you can bring it for your camp
but it's a pretty good pretty good ways
i know where they're gonna have jam
tracks and all that and hopefully they
figure that out and also they're gonna
search it they'll search for it
but i'm just saying you don't wanna you
don't wanna have something you're gonna
have to carry around for seven eight
hours or more
um all right
well you might consider getting a locker
in cineroop because you can rent them
for i don't know how much but you know
then just throw all your stuff in there
if you're that's an option
you know floor taco yet again our
connection to the common man
who does this i i had no idea about the
lockers i had no idea
we got a locker at shakiness did you
really how much did it cost you
it was
i don't remember but it was worth every
penny it was you know 20 or 30 bucks
holy [ __ ] did you ever the whole weekend
or is that per day
no it was the whole weekend and we we
split it i mean yeah if you've got a
friend i mean you can easily split a
locker and just put your blankets or
jackets or whatever you got um and then
they it also comes with a phone charger
you get a battery pack to charge your
phone whoa
you get to keep the battery pack or does
it stay with them
you give them a 10 deposit and then when
you return the battery you get the 10
bucks back got it i didn't know that
that's really clever well and hopefully
they do that at bonner too because it's
a great idea that's a good idea it's the
same people yeah they're gonna do it um
i'm pretty sure yeah my third self-care
tip
yes baby powder works it is one of the
most emasculating things that i've ever
done in my life
um because once you do it
here's the thing about baby powder
is that there's no escaping the fact
that everyone knows you just powdered
yourself
there's no way around it
and
like i you can't just like subtly go
behind a tree or into your thing and
powder where you need to go no because
there's no easy way to get it into the
thing so just because
yeah all of oh you're right stuff and
you look like a gymnast getting on the
pole vault
oh god it is a lifesaver it is an
absolute lifesaver and it's one of these
things where if i could figure out if
somebody could invent a baby powder
thing and maybe somebody knows the
answer to this but if somebody could
invent a baby powder thing that didn't
have all of the you know cloudiness to
it
uh
oh god i need it in this city so bad
i mean i have already in this city
multiple times we're like
all right just take a l let me side
saddle this seat for a second
nice
that's a good tip though yeah
again plan for comfort uh um
i my final no i always have one more
another crazy self-care tip
and i know this one's gonna be batshit
crazy but just give it a try before you
go there maybe you don't like them but
it's worth a try
the wife turned me on to i had this so
when i was a kid i was convinced that i
had an invention that was going to
change the world and that was netflix it
did but my other invention i did i had
that
i had this i invented the moped
i really did
i really think that every kid has got
the the invention that's going to change
the world every kid's got one
yeah i i you can ask any nine-year-old
right now they've got some sort of
bashir crazy idea that elon musk will
have in 15 years and all of us are like
why in the hell didn't we do that yeah
so this was mine
when i was a kid i hated as a kid
brushing my teeth i always said why
can't i just take a pill and pop it into
my mouth and boom have my
teeth brushed done should be much easier
than this
well
i said that in passing one day and
hillary goes you mean like these
and handed me a jar full of toothpaste
tablets
toothpaste tablets it's a real thing
you take the toothpaste tablet you pop
it in your mouth you swish it around for
about 90 seconds to two minutes you spit
or you can swallow
you spit it out you rinse it out with
water your mouth
game changer
game changer okay if i've had a bad day
i pop in a tablet i'm just walking
around the office i don't have to brush
it
i do carry a toothpaste and toothbrush
in my work bag but the toothpaste
tablets are so much easier they're so
much more convenient and if you are
somebody like a russ or brian who is
going to risk it with hooking up at
bonnaroo even though i'm telling you not
to do it
use the toothpaste tablets better than
mouthwash
my other one and i i've said this every
year is uh don't bring ice you know
bring your cooler go and buy a case of
uh bottled water and freeze it
and use that as the ice in your cooler
it doesn't get sloshy it doesn't make
your food wet and it's drinkable so
it's that's the best tip that i ever got
um
it you know
if they for the most part i they stay
frozen till almost the end and so on
sunday i'm drinking ice cold water
um
you know i mean i hate the the plastic
and what all that's doing
but as far as uh convenience that's
that's been a good one for me
uh does taco have any more health
safety or self-care tips before we uh
get to our last one
i know this is not your department
probably the i'm probably the last
person to give self-care tips so no i
think you covered it
uh all right
uh my final one
and i know not everybody agrees with me
on this and it's a little bit harder to
pull off in in ga but if you can
ah man i think that there's not a better
feeling on that farm than a late night
shower absolutely the 2 a.m shower there
is nothing that feels better than going
to sleep clean
cleanish cleanish
there's nothing better than that feeling
i absolutely am obsessed with that 2am
three i'm sure actually i don't care how
late it is i really don't it
really matt doesn't matter to me and the
later the better plus the rush in the
morning
is
yeah who wants to deal with that that's
a good one uh also along those lines
bring water and actual soap
i remember first couple of years i just
used like hand sanitizers
and made the mistake of leaving yeah
leaving the camp and stopping at that
gas station across the way there and
washed my hands
for somebody who does for someone who
doesn't know for somebody who doesn't
know how do you transport your soap
uh well i mean i bar soap in a plastic i
understand but what if you drop the bar
soap that's a goner never picking that
i don't drop this so brad i learned that
at you know
boys school
[Laughter]
soap
boys
i never enrolled in boys school so
you're right you never went to boyce
school
that sounds like the place you do drop
the soapberry
no i never had that issue uh brad
but don't just rely on hand sanitizers
uh
you know soap and water well this is
where this is where i would think i
would i like having a friend in the
hotel industry
because i like having the teeny tiny
little soaps that i can carry and if
something were to happen i can just
run right through it i carry i bring
like 10 of them i mean
well i'll tell you what i got
i've got the little
soap dispenser a little squeeze bottle
with a suction cup on the side so you
get in the shower you don't have a place
to set it down you stick it to the wall
and it stays there okay there you go see
yeah but in those boundary showers i
don't think you need the suction cup for
stuff to stick on the side
you know you can
and uh i've heard other people i think
charlotte on the on the real rubus
they've been talking some of these tips
and they made a lot of sense of this
start now
start now buying your stuff you know
some of your uh
your uh
toiletries and whatnot rather than
having them
rather than wait until the day you know
the weekend up or whatever and spending
all that yeah but i'm having a really
hard time with this sticking something
to the side of the shower and the bottom
thing this is really getting very weird
have you seen some of the things that on
the side of that wall
honestly you know what i you know what
oh my god it's got a great idea
i would totally bring before i got into
that shower what is that spray bottle of
like clean clean the shower thing
i would recommend just start spraying
the thing down just so i feel a little
bit better about myself
yeah why not just spray yourself with it
and skip the shower i'm okay with that
yeah
um
so you can get a lot of the you start
buying now you know your your walmarts
and your dollar stores have you know the
travel size shampoos and soaps and all
those things
start buying them now you can you're
you don't you know obviously not gonna
buy your food perishable foods and stuff
stuff right now but uh
start getting that so you're not hit
with a big ticket you know big cost all
at once
um
yeah
somebody did somebody on twitter did i
see oh yeah somebody asked me about hair
care tips
um
i uh first off
i have none to share because it always
looks perfect
secondly um what i have noticed is that
um it is better for me truly to not wash
my hair
um because
if you're a guy like me who wants it you
know to you know
barry can get out of the shower and it's
just there i take a little bit it needs
a little bit of work right um and i'm
very particular what i found is that i i
just i can't get the heat to relent
enough for my hair to do what i want it
to do so it's better that i just don't
wash it which makes the showering
process so much easier i'm not carrying
around a whole bunch of shampoo
but in a pinch
shampoo is an easy soap
if you really need to
they they they when avita was the big
sponsor i mean i i had
and i had dropped the soap and it was a
goner so i just loaded up on a whole
bunch of a vida shampoo
and you'll never make it in boys school
[Laughter]
i've disappointed dad so bad
i'm so sorry dad hey brad i could see
him with a bag of like
10 soaps well that one's gone but gotta
get another one
[Music]
gotta bring out disappointed
disappointed my whole family um all
right
oh the last thing that i had for you and
and
and it's because we've tried this at our
camp and i'm willing to be uh i'm
willing to have my mind change but barry
corder lord taco what are your thoughts
on the disposable camera
oh it was a good idea
um
it was a fun idea it didn't work uh
didn't work for whatever reason didn't
work yeah
it felt doesn't work and it's so
expensive it is so expensive yeah
so here's here's what here's our exp our
experience with the um
with the throwaway camera the disposable
camera great theory fantastic the
polaroids work better
if you have if you're willing to spend
the money on one of these things the
polaroid things work a lot better in
fact i've got one around here somewhere
uh because you know we had a polaroid of
camp one time but the disposable cameras
the problem is you're never gonna get
enough light and the times that you're
using them they just don't work like you
remember them working you can point them
at things but you're not taking a
picture of anything and that's just not
what i remember happening back in the
day when i had a disposable camera i
thought that i was always taking these
perfect pictures but we did this we must
have had 12 of them
12 35 pictures a piece i mean we had 300
pictures five of them were usable yeah
it felt a little
i mean it felt a little like you
were asking somebody to work
not work but plan
you know like you had to carry it around
you had to have it with you when the
right moment or you had to intentionally
go out to look for pictures
it was a great idea
i mean that wasn't what i wanted i
wouldn't just no no no i'm not being
ugly about it just you know it's typical
of me with a camera it's like i never
have my phone which has a camera but you
know it's
you never have it when
the perfect picture is is available
or
now you gotta care anyway it was a great
idea but you're right i think we got
three pictures
yeah it was just terrible i don't even
know where they are anymore yeah so all
right um i'm sure there's more let us
know the what underscore podcast on the
twits and the instagrams or um i don't
even know if we have a facebook but uh
let us know
yeah let us know some of yours or even
the whatpodcast.com and drop it in the
comments so um speaking of yeah do we
you mentioned the uh the hair care tip
somebody did say they'd love for us to
do bona roulette we would love to do it
but it's kind of hard to do
with the copyright laws anymore so
also remotely
yeah remotely it's pretty difficult we
the last time we did we were all
together
yeah yep yeah it was a lot of fun with
taco and his sound effects
but yeah
anyway
all right all right you guys are the
best if you uh think of anything else
let us know um
anything else where we go yeah um
dropping a shout out to rewbust they're
having their wednesday night pre-party
out at the bus uh they're having flip
turn is the band
i'm a bigger fan i'm a bigger fan of
turn flip
should also uh thank consequence again
thank you for letting us be a part of
the consequence podcast network are they
going to be there
yeah you know what that's a great
question
yeah
we haven't even
talked with them about plans and we've
got to talk to alex consequence i'm sure
he's good yeah
all right
all right guys you're the best
talk to you next week what podcast love
you bye
[Music]
consequence podcast network